foreign
[Music]
credits twerking in the next episode's
pre-credits previously on just to really
make sure meme culture got sick of it as
quickly as possible is
it too LED it says right on the box that
it's just plain old regular LED so the
sin of course is not reading parking
your getaway van directly under the only
street light in view so security cameras
can get a better quality image of the
would-be burglars when I park it over
here where it's darker I know you've got
to walk further but hey even criminals
shouldn't Skip Leg Day
roll catchphrase Marshalls also what
exactly was the plan here if the suit
didn't malfunction to fly high in the
air away from the bad guys and then land
50 feet away I guess and you guessed it
I have third degree burns all over my
legs no you have third degree burns on
the lower half of your legs your thighs
unfortunately appear to be unharmed if
both of his legs are injured to the
point that he shouldn't have weight on
them wouldn't that be a wheelchair
situation and not a crutch situation
show doesn't know how to ambulatory
correctly I suggest that you try to come
to an agreement with Mr Jacobson so then
the filing would not be necessary except
Jen wouldn't be negotiating directly
with Mr Jacobson she should be
negotiating with his attorney a flaw I
believe we already send back in episode
6 where Mr immortal's Ex-Wives were
settling without their own legal
representation present so here's 10 sins
for bungling law yet again and only four
minutes into the episode new record I've
never made a defective suit in all my
life my work is impeccable never is a
pretty strong statement dude everyone
makes mistake aches you might not have
in this instance but I'm sure you've
aired in at least one suit throughout
your career you know what they say about
pride and falls right it's a sin
She-Hulk will never get another suit by
Luke Jacobson ever again nonsense Drake
ramoray inherited the brain of Jessica
Lockhart have I seen such a well-acted
scene that ended in the words ever again
double Janet Jackson in your fashion
dummy without explicit consent Mr
Jacobson I see you are presently without
counsel are you representing yourself if
Mr Jacobson was representing himself
that would have been made clear in a
filing with the judge before this
hearing ever began but of course the
show wants to set up a dramatic reveal
as if we'd excuse more shoddy legal
writing for such a thing then where is
your counsel oh he's late not for any
good reason really other than he wanted
to make a big entrance because
apparently he was on his own show a
while back on Netflix those Netflix big
shots they like to make an entrance you
know also inadvertently making Iron Fist
MCU Cannon I'd like to ask that the
opposing council's motion to compel
production of The defendant's Client
List be rejected as it's not relevant to
the litigation who's this [__]
calling an attorney an [__] for
displaying a superior knowledge of law
compared to what you've demonstrated up
until this point it's a gross invasion
of people's privacy based on a very
shaky what if Jeffrey Wright isn't
narrating me in this scene I remind you
that the sokovia courts have been
repealed no you may not in fact you're
not allowed to ever mention the scovia
courts again we're all tired of it
thanks for asking also the sokovia
Accords were an international agreement
among 117 Nations placing Direct Control
of the Avengers under a United Nations
body nothing in the Accords pertain to
public identities of superheroes and
would hardly be relevant in a local
warranty case in Los Angeles but hey
Marvel's got a Marvel I guess yes we can
all tell his lie Mr Murdoch making an
immediate judgment based on how we can
all tell what's going on here assumption
instead of you know due process an
Appletini cute scene does not include a
Dr John Dorian also ordering an
Appletini at the bar mind if I join you
sure sure as in you do mind doesn't this
mean he should just stay put why do
people always answer this question wrong
Luke Jacobson made a couple of new suits
for me
I owed him one it doesn't really look
like it it's a low blow insulting a
blind man's clothes
okay these two are fire together I want
more of this I want all of this I stand
she devil or Dare Hulk whatever take
your son off so we can move on his dad
is a very important client so he is a
very important client nepo babies or the
entire nepo baby discourse take your
pick
she all can help people and the law
fails that works for you because the
public doesn't know your identity if
Matt Murdoch can't help a client
Daredevil can and none of it Strays back
to you everyone knows Janice She-Hulk so
if she uses violence to help a client it
just backfire on them in court we're all
feeling this right it's not just me sure
but I'm more concerned that you haven't
touched that Appletini yet which
honestly makes you a teeny bit of an
[__] oh you remember Todd that gross
Tech bro with the She-Hulk fetish yes
you previously owned him to us just 11
minutes ago which you should remember
since you were there Kool-Aid Manning
the fourth wall is normal I mean you
gotta see it right
so here it is check this out actually
what I'd rather check out is the process
your thumbs went through on that phone
to open up the picture can we Replay
that why is he using both thumbs like
he's texting when he's opening a picture
wearing your high heels on a couch
actually wearing your high heels even
one microsecond longer than necessary
our first move the person you're trying
to save is in this vehicle currently
suffering from Whiplash you just caused
ass remains unwoofed
okay one more sin removal for Charlie
Cox but this is the last time I mean it
Throwing Cars at people whoa whoa whoa
dead even with his hearing damaged in
season three map put up a better fight
than this but Jen lifts him up and he's
unmasked like that damn that's some
Disney neutering right there hope
Daredevil reborn isn't like this also
why is Jin immediately transforming back
just because she knows it's Matt now he
could still be dangerous and there's no
reason not to stay Hulk well no
non-budgetary reason but I assume the
guy dressed as the devil was the bad one
that's Satanist oh crap I'll go leave a
note saying what hey She-Hulk here sorry
for wrecking your private property do
you have the money to pay for a
destroyed sports car and repaving a
garage and lot is your Law Firm going to
pay for it she'll writes this off as a
joke but there's some serious legal
questions here going unanswered subtle I
know right you are talking about the
blatant and clunky promotion QR coding
that these shows continue to do correct
I can't believe this dodo he's a frog
not a Dodo gin and you can't just make
up animals once your next fake creature
going to be named a puma a walrus now
stop talking and go back to Smashing
private that's an order
smashing privates I can hear their
heartbeats you can hear their heartbeats
come on I was a little far-fetched Jen
Walters would be excellent at TV since I
actually know she wouldn't that would be
a boring sin make a pun or something I
got it tell him you didn't realize he
was heart of hearing
never mind maybe your way was better
yeah good thing She-Hulk is
indestructible Matthew oh the more
reason it's ridiculous that you're still
standing here is Jen
is that guy using a mini crossbow how is
that even frog themed why don't these
goons have guns like Matt said they
would can I ask whose idea was to design
these hallways with dim blue lighting
was it the action coordinator wanting to
be able to hide the seams in the action
I bet it was
She-Hulk smash depriving your audience
of more Daredevil hand-to-hand combat in
favor of a horrible catchphrase from gin
did the writers even watch any of the
Netflix show it's even on Disney plus
now oh whoa whoa hey I spent it no Jen
grabbed the leap Frogger game which is
clearly your custom knockoff the Frogger
arcade unit which actually is vintage
remains intact temper insanity is murky
but it's not a bad strategy an angle
this more is a form of traumatic
expression due to undiagnosed PTSD
playing Daredevil's advocate
[Music]
and sadder that he went for the shoulder
AKA The sturdiest Blocking muscle in the
body
earlier in the electronic supply store
parking lot you fell from at least twice
this height and were fine why did this
specific fall destroy you is it because
the episode's almost over and the
writers need the story to wrap up I bet
it was you'll make my gala dress yes of
course I'm not a monster
trying to get too bloated between now
and then you know what he is monstrous
body shaming and aren't all of her
clothes designed to stretch for
transformation why would a little
bloating even matter thanks for your
help with
help thanks for your help ego flirting
you cannot tell me there's not at least
some Paparazzi outside of Jen's house at
all hours to get pictures of She-Hulk
this is LA and Daredevil thinks it's
cool to just walk in wearing his costume
come on this would be photographed on
social media before moaning I'm sorry
morning before morning does anyone else
ever wonder hmm what if the MCU had been
meant for grown adults with rated R
movies and TV MA shows he asks right now
at this moment for no particular reason
weird you guys are still here hold on
let me just take a roll call of everyone
who laughed at this bit um Bueller
Bueller Bueller seriously what is this
scene this episode already came to a
very satisfying conclusion trust me
shaming your episode for wanting its
conclusion to come twice his next
episode
Lord willing and the creek don't rise
Jen then we can go back to sitting
something more fun like Mando oh there's
another Hulk but this one's red
reminding me that we haven't gotten to
see General Thunderbolt Ross's roll kiet
oh no Marvel you will not be getting
away with these Wolverine teases without
delivering soon and now I need to see
him transform his adamantium claws into
makeup utensils so you've really painted
yourself into a corner now and it's kind
of your own fault this year's female
lawyer of the Year award goes to
Jennifer She-Hulk Walters
nice fake out but aside from
manufacturing a surprise what reason is
This MC putting such an emphasis on the
first name he reads and leaving that
huge space before announcing the second
name and what order are they even being
announced in descending height
really is
oh my identity is not a a secret
this is busted this is the truth
sure was nice of intelligency to build
in that seven second pause in the video
for She-Hulk to comment and get in a
microphone joke very considerate don't
do it Jen that's it that was
intelligencia's plan to ruin the
reputation of She-Hulk show the world
that she's an adult who engages in
consensual sex with other adults I mean
a mortifying invasion of privacy sure
I'm not downplaying the psychological
damage it could do to Jen as a person
but this was supposed to be a big scary
intelligence organization right wouldn't
video of Jen destroying that parking lot
be more publicly damaging to leak wait
how did the specialized military Squad
get here so fast Jen just smashed those
screens and they geared up traveled
across LA and arrived here in the
minutes and she did that one of they
have frog jets in their gear General is
in control and hulking out in Rage is
actually a fascinating concept I can't
wait to explore I'm super glad we have
lots of time to dig into this and they
didn't wait until the penultimate
episode to address it
thank you
they loved him up and turned him into a
horny toad
I want to see the super suit that Luke
made you where's my super suit I have
been retained by a client who suffered
serious injuries due to a dysfunctional
suit that you sold him now nothing has
been filed so I think we can come
dare you I used to design for Gods I
love wakanda you know I actually studied
abroad there really wakanda forever
don't ever do that again go call the
police
what do you want I just wanted to get
your name
in trouble look I don't like
me I feel like this episode should be
over hello
what's it like being a female lawyer oh
it's infantilizing bollocks I think it's
a subsection of success